today's question comes from monica in
nebraska
we are on baby step two and we are in a
large amount of debt because of various
stupid
decisions my husband is really not
interested in working this program
i am the one that does all the financial
stuff and i am the main br
breadwinner he has basically said tell
him
what he can be spent on various
categories and he will make it happen
so i've decided to work the debt
snowball is it wrong to move forward
when he isn't
really supportive well
so monica the deal is the when you're
married when you both can work together
and be on the same team and go towards
the same goals you have the same vision
you're gonna get there faster because
you're both gonna be willing to
sacrifice
you're both thinking about it day in and
day out like that is what you're working
towards as a team
so you're going to get progress a lot
faster it doesn't
sound like he's not necessarily not
supportive he's kind of like just tell
me where i can spend it and i'll spend
it and that's kind of it he's kind of
checked out i wish he was more
emotionally not interested in working
this program but he said just tell him
what he can
what can be spent in cert in various
categories and he can i would tell him
i'm not your mother
be a man go down to walmart on aisle
three and pick you up a backbone
oh okay no really monica you little wuss
seriously you need to step up you need
to man up and walk with your wife
beside her yes he does but he's not
asking the question it's monica so what
does monica do i know
monica needs to call him out
can you imagine if i walked in and told
your mother
that i didn't really care and you just
do whatever you want and you take care
of everything and i'm just gonna sit
over here in the corner and wish can you
imagine what your mother would do
she would unjoint my butt that wouldn't
even come close
no really i mean call him i know but
welcome
to this is this is this is a lot of this
is a lot of people situations though in
america it really is
and it's the woman is has become the one
she is the cfo of the household i mean
she really is the one doing the money
doing everything uh in regards to money
and so
you have to realize women out there
number one that when your husband is on
board you win
faster so what do you do about it number
two go and i would say sit down and have
a frank conversation as
respectful as you would like or as
davism
as you would like to take it that's up
to you but to say hey here here's what
i'm feeling here's what i'm thinking
here are my fears here are my whys why
do i want to win why do i want to get
out of debt
and talk to him have a relationship have
communication so you guys can get on the
same team
and so when that doesn't happen i'd also
say bring in a third party i mean at
that point at that point you have more
marriage issues than money issues
because you're not willing to work
together and in marriage
that's what marriage is you are living
life together and you're unified
in every subject including money so
monica rachel's right about one thing
you are you are one hundred percent more
capable
than he is you have the natural gifting
you're the cfo of the household
i am not discounting that at all and so
you're the one that's probably going to
implement the plan you're probably even
going to design the plan
but this idea that he gets to sit over
in the corner and be spoon-fed
whatever he just tell me when i can
spend
oh brother that's just ridiculous
that's absolutely absurd and so you're
going you're probably the one that has
the
the greater talent in this area and
obviously the greater concern for
that's not going to change but he does
need to step up and say all right i'll
walk with you in this dream
i'm going to come with you let's look
together at the budget you do the budget
i'll look at it with you
you're probably going to be the one that
produces it because she's the cfo of the
household i don't care if there's a man
the woman that's the cfo
that's not my point but i got to tell
you she's going to end up really
frustrated with him being a wuss like
this
and it's going to damage their
relationship because i have
coached people in these situations after
ladies try to do this for 10 years
and she finally is tired of being
married to a little boy yeah no
that's what i was saying earlier though
is a lot of women possibly listening
right the second
are is exactly in her situation they are
finding themselves that their husbands
do not want to participate
don't want to go along with it not that
they're not that they're saying oh i
wouldn't know he's just
passive it's the pat yes it's that
passion yeah
and that's just that's just gross
seriously and this is yes and the
wussification of america
and the the deal too is that we say
life problems usually masquerade
themselves as money problems so there's
probably other areas in her marriage i'm
assuming that she's frustrated that he's
not whether it's
kids or whatever the situation is
there's a that's the person
that's what's that's the roles that have
been in place not just with money and so
being able to help him get on board
is going to help also the marriage
exactly because we it's
a prerequisite to you winning here yeah
absolutely you are not going to be able
to pull this off
with this with the formula that you're
using it's not going to work
i mean it may work for a little while
but eventually it's going to blow up for
relational reasons and financial reasons
um he may get tired of being dictated to
at some point
um you know being told my iphone let me
do this i mean what kind of hook gross
and so um you know that that so
that it's going to blow up it's not
going to work we've done it too long i
mean 30 years of doing this i've watched
this situation unfold over and over
again
so what he has to do and you have to
call him out on this or go see a
third-party marriage counselor together
what rachel's saying is exactly right on
that
um the you have got to go
and get not he doesn't need to become a
nerd and he doesn't need to become the
one that drives the budget
but he's got to be in agreement and he
has to actively emotionally vote
and say all right i i look at that i
agree that that taking those steps is
going to take us to a dream
i agree on that's a lot different than
city and then
you go and do the stuff that's fine no
problem with that but when he's just
sitting back and you're trying to drag
him along
and he just gets his little allowance oh
my gosh